[Music]
on this monday night
bc's wildfire fight gets a boost
the reinforcements arriving and the
restlessness among anxious residents our
mountain is on fire
and i have no idea what's happening
today restrictions lifted for fully
vaccinated canadian travelers
what they still need to do and what the
changes could mean for the canada-us
border
the remainder of the collapsed florida
condo
demolished how this will help crews with
the rescue operation
and making a racket it's a dream come
true you know the two canadian tennis
star is about to serve up history
at wimbledon
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin in british columbia and the
escalating efforts to get those raging
wildfires under control
nearly a hundred firefighters from other
provinces are set to land in bc
tonight they'll be tested for covet 19
before being dispatched to regions most
in need
support also coming from the canadian
armed forces
it will help airlift fire crews and
supplies
into and out of wildfire zones and help
with emergency evacuations
if needed
crews are now on a new front line
battling a wildfire in the southern
okanagan valley
the fire is still small about one
hectare in size
but it is considered out of control at
the present time
it's threatening at least one home and
its force the closure
off the highway leading to a soyuz the
area is under a heat warning with
temperatures
in the low to mid 30s
this is what fire crews are contending
with across the province more than 190
fires are actively burning
more than 60 of them are out of control
13 are considered wildfires of note
meaning they pose a threat to public
safety
and in large parts of pc the weather has
been so hot and dry
that the risk of new wildfires starting
is considered high
to extreme what happened last week
in the village of litton is a
devastating example of how quickly fires
can spread
at least two people were killed
officials say it's now
suspected the fire was human caused
global's robin gill has tonight's top
story
and the race to contain bc's fires and
how communities
are coping canon lake relies on tourism
for two months in the summer
but no tourists are arriving in this
small resort community
and reservations are being canceled it
would be packed
with like 150 people right now and it's
empty there's nobody here
because they're scared now the owner of
the main resort is packing up
ready to go at a moment's notice my
whole life is in a truck and on a boat
right now because we might have to go
cadm lake is caught between two fires
angus mccurley spent a sleepless night
watching the flames that are creeping
toward his house
just as worrisome are the whipping winds
it
comes back with a vengeance without a
wind and when the wind comes
we're in trouble residents of litton
still aren't allowed to go back to check
the damage to their village
ninety percent of the homes and
buildings have been destroyed
so the investigation into the linton
creek fire is being led by the rcmp with
the support of the bc wildfire service
at this time it is suspected to be human
caused
they all started with one point of
ignition one match
one dropped cigarette butt one lightning
strike
mike anderson has lived in deadman's
valley his whole life
and knows what kind of damage a fire can
do if we don't get on top of this
you know this has devastating effects on
on first nations
has devastating effects on the ranching
industry devastating effects on the
forestry industry
there are ten active evacuation orders
in bc
and five alerts the province is holding
information meetings for those forced
from their homes
and there's a sense of hopelessness the
situation that we're in right now
is not ideal
and many of you folks are out of your
places right now
you don't know what's going on you don't
know when you'll be back
the warm weather isn't ideal and
temperamental winds
can turn instantly we've just been
really lucky with the winds that it
hasn't come this way
but if we get unlucky which our luck
will run out at some point
we're in trouble leaving lives and
livelihoods
in limbo robin gill global news
vancouver
today is july 5th that means new rules
are now in effect for canadian travelers
so starting today fully vaccinated
canadians returning home
can skip quarantine if they test
negative but it's not open season on
summer vacation travel just yet
the government is still advising against
non-essential travel
abigail beeman has the details on the
changes
i'm pretty ecstatic among the first to
arrive back home in montreal bruce
burnett describes himself as a guinea
pig for the new rules when the flight
attendants announced
process they're talking about three days
in the hotel and quarantine has said
you guys are aware that it's changed
today and they were not aware of the
fact
on the plane they had to call into the
ground crew to find out what was going
on
as a fully vaccinated canadian he won't
need to quarantine
nor will he need a day eight test rules
that have been frustrating for many
i told my wife who was in town with
other stuff that
if they don't open up the borders i'm
not coming back i was ready to stay in
israel as long as necessary
it's not a fully open border only
canadians and others already
exempt are allowed in everyone still
needs to present a negative pcr test
result upon arrival
and take another when they get here you
also need a new version of arrivecan to
upload proof of vaccination
and your test result wow it was super
complicated because also it changed so
many times
first was the end of the day then like
one week ago they changed to the
beginning of the day
and we already have a flight many still
have questions
i think the biggest challenge that we
have is really getting the message out
in regards to
what has changed while the public health
agency of canada put out a new statement
stressing it is
still not the time to travel i know how
eager people are
to get things back to normal but things
aren't normal yet calling monday's rule
change a big
step at an announcement in northern
ontario the prime minister was pressed
on the
next steps for a fulsome reopening and
why
vaccinated americans are still not
welcome we're going to stay safe
but we're very hopeful that we're going
to be able to say new steps
on see new steps on reopening announced
in the coming weeks
coming weeks trudeau said the same thing
two weeks ago
all eyes are now on july 21st for the
next chance of reopening
monday the prime minister said the next
phase whenever announced would allow
other fully vaccinated people to enter
canada
abigail beeman global news ottawa
ontario premier doug ford says his
government is guaranteeing it will keep
the temporary wage bump
brought in during the pandemic for
personal support workers
right now those who staff long-term care
homes and similar facilities
get an extra three dollars per hour the
benefit's been extended until august
23rd
but ford says he's committed to keeping
it
okay i've always said uh folks psws are
overworked underpaid
and they they deserve uh every single
penny times ten
so we're going to keep that in place the
three dollars an hour uh pay for them
the pay bump has been in place since
last october affecting more than 158
thousand workers
at today's coveted briefing in nova
scotia things took a turn
with a surprise admission from the
premier
in 2003 i was found to be driving under
the influence
i was fined and my license was suspended
for one year
two years later i was charged with the
same offense but was eventually found to
be innocent
ian rankin says he makes no excuses for
his behavior
and is sorry the 38 year old also says
he disclosed the information when he ran
for the liberal leadership
rankin who had never addressed the
charges publicly says they
weren't a secret but heard people asking
questions about the cases and wanted to
explain
there has also been widespread
speculation about a
looming election call just days before
the start of the much-anticipated
calgary stampede
city council has voted to repeal its
mask rules
the change isn't fully in effect but it
will bring the city in line with the
rest of alberta
and bc where mask rules ended last week
now calgary's mayor says he's confident
public safety
isn't being put at risk but as heather
urex west explains
not all experts agree open for business
no mask required dining out in western
canada
is now looking more and more like it did
before covet 19.
it's just a nice step to feel like we're
going back to normal it feels
great feels like we got out of jail
mayor and she yes
that has carried your worship 10 to 4.
calgary city council voted 10 to 4
monday to repeal its mass by-law putting
the city in line with the rest of the
province
infection rates are almost as low as
they were when we put in the bylaw last
summer
and hospitalization and icu rates are
still higher than they were last summer
but they're really trending downward bc
and alberta both rescinded their
provincial mass mandates on july
1st while saskatchewan's mandate could
be lifted as early as next week
but provincial territorial mass mandates
remain in effect in all
other parts of the country and could
remain in place for several months
toronto's bilo won't be up for debate
again until the fall
we are not seeing any widespread
dissemination of any of the new more
dangerous variants
and the vaccine program is going very
well
dr brian conway says removing mass
policies now
makes sense though he believes they may
be required again if
outbreaks take hold in my opinion i'd
like to see
us hang on to the mask by law a little
bit longer and
the reason why i say that is although we
have really good first
dose vaccine coverage we're still
lagging behind a little bit in the
second doses
while more than 75 percent of canadians
12 and over
have received a first dose of vaccine
less than a third of the population
is fully vaccinated and unfortunately
the current
version of the virus that's out there in
the community this delta variant
is actually pretty good at infecting
people that only have one shot of
vaccine
calgary's bylaw change also means masks
will no longer be required for indoor
venues at the calgary stampede which
kicks off
later this week with thousands set to
attend
heather urex west global news calgary
and british prime minister boris johnson
says people in england will no longer
have to wear masks in indoor public
spaces
or keep one meter apart when
restrictions lift as planned in two
weeks time
though masks will still be recommended
in some enclosed spaces
england is planning to move to its final
stage of its reopening plan
july 19th but with warnings about a
rising cases due to the highly
transmissible delta variant
a final decision will be made next week
i want to stress from the outset that
this pandemic is
far from over it certainly won't be over
by the 19th
as we predicted in the road map in
february we're seeing cases
rise fairly rapidly there could be 50
000
cases detected per day by the 19th
sixty four percent of people in the uk
are fully vaccinated
britain has recorded more than a hundred
and twenty eight thousand deaths from
coven 19
that is the most in western europe
and britain's royal family says the
duchess of cambridge is self-isolating
after coming into contact with someone
who
later tested positive for covet 19. kay
was supposed to attend events with
prince william today
to celebrate the 73rd birthday of
britain's national health service
the palace says the duchess who's fully
vaccinated has no symptoms
she began her 10-day self-isolation
period on friday after spending most of
the day
at the wimbledon tennis championship the
collapsed florida condo reduced to
rubble
coming up what rescue crews can do now
as they search
for victims plus gunman's storm a
nigerian school
the abduction of more than a hundred
students
dozens of homes gone in seconds a
controlled demolition brought down what
remained of that collapsed
condo building in surf side florida
miami-dade county's mayor ordered the
demolition saying it was
critical to expand the scope of the
search for victims
there were concerns about the
structure's stability officials were
also worried strong winds from the
approaching tropical storm elsa
could pose even further safety risks at
the site
despite the fact that the likelihood of
finding survivors lessons
by the day officials are still calling
this a search and rescue mission
the bodies of three more victims have
been found in the rubble and that brings
the death toll to 28.
117 people remain unaccounted for and
four canadians are listed
among those missing jackson proskow
looks at the next steps
it took just seconds to bring down the
biggest threat in the search for the
missing
a staged implosion toppled the damaged
structure away from the debris pile
where dozens remain unaccounted for
we wanted to move that building if we
could safely do so
so that we could gain access to that
pile wiping out the remainder of the
champlain tower meant destroying
survivors personal belongings
it was just too unsafe to recover
anything
without the threat of further collapse
crews can now dig with heavy equipment
for the first time
gaining access to areas where it's
believed the majority of the victims are
located
because that newly accessible area where
it was
that happened to be where a lot of the
master bedrooms are
it's still officially a rescue operation
officials acknowledge there's little
hope of finding survivors
there's a lot of families and friends
that are still hoping to recover their
loved ones
betty matzgelski's close friend
graziella katarasi and her
seven-year-old daughter were among the
victims recovered
the rest of the family is still missing
in graciela's apartment was herself her
daughter her sister andrea and her
parents
and as far as i know only graciela
and her daughter have been recovered the
other three
still remain to be found rescue crews
insist
the only thing that will slow them down
now is the weather
tropical storm elsa is expected to hit
florida later this week
it won't make a direct hit on surfside
but could still deliver heavy rain
the search will continue for 24 hours a
day seven days a week
until we pull everybody out of that
rubble all the while
debris is carted away for forensic
analysis
continuing the search for answers amidst
the search for victims
jackson prosko global news washington
ahead what caused this explosion in the
caspian sea
this is a fire explosion off the coast
of azerbaijan last night
it was a mud volcano erupting on a small
island in the caspian sea
azerbaijan is known for its mud
volcanoes there are hundreds of them
on shore and offshore due to the
country's vast oil and gas fields
azerbaijan nicknames itself the land of
fire
and is famous for a site where natural
gas vents
out of fissures in the ground igniting
into what are essentially
eternal flames
it is the last day on the job for amazon
ceo
jeff bezos bezos founded amazon 27 years
ago today
it started as an online book retailer he
of course grew that company into a 1.7
trillion dollar tech titan and it made
him
one of the richest men in the world andy
jassy
who has led amazon's web services since
2006 is going to take the helm
bezos will serve as the company's
executive chair the 57 year old also
plans to turn his focus onto other
projects like space travel
later this month he's scheduled to join
the first crewed flight
of the new shepherded rocket built by
his aerospace company
blue origin at least 140 students have
been kidnapped from a school in
northwestern nigeria
families of the children are desperate
for news on their loved ones
police say a gunman overpowered school
security guards
broke through a wall and entered a
dormitory early this morning
a teacher and about 25 students escaped
more than 800 students have been
abducted in nigeria since december
most have been released after
negotiations but at least 150
remain missing virtual
date night no more next cross-border
couples back together physically as
border rules ease
it's the moment many canadians have been
waiting for
reuniting with loved ones after a long
long separation
canada's easing of coven 19 travel
restrictions allows fully vaccinated
canadians
and permanent residents to enter the
country without having to quarantine
the rules have been a burden for
cross-border couples keeping apart
throughout much of this pandemic
as mike drolie explains the roadblocks
are still though in place
for some in the shadow of the giant
peace arch monument straddling the u.s
canada border
sits a grassy haven from the unforgiven
confines of covet rules
there's no wall or border station here
it's witnessed weddings and now has
pop-up tents for people to reunite
and share more private moments but
that's just here
the rules everywhere else have been
complicated which is why
melinda schneider is happy her mom is a
lawyer
i have someone who reads that all day
every day so for her she's like oh it
means this this this this whereas like
i'm looking at it and it's like
throwing me back to calculus and give me
ptsd the teacher's college student had
to figure it out so she could see her
boyfriend adrian
who lives and works in denmark they
managed to visit each other last year
once in denmark another time in canada
but the financial and emotional burdens
of kovid
started to become too much i got laid
off and then it's like oh now my
boyfriend can't come in oh i have no
freedom and oh i can't leave my house
and then it's like oh i can't have my
friends over i can't see my family
but now with new rules meant to ease
travel restrictions for fully vaccinated
canadians
she sees a pathway towards normalcy i
feel a little more free
because it's like you know like i've
done my part you know what i mean but
that freedom isn't assured for couples
across the board
since benefits aren't yet extended to
fully vaccinated foreign nationals
so when dr david poon's partner arise
from ireland this week
the mandatory 15-day stay still applies
so a canadian essentially has full
mobility
a foreign national family member of a
canadian does not
he'd like to see that change soon but
nothing
coveted related seems to move quickly
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm farah nasser
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
canada is west beach in fort hope
ontario
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]